[Music]
oil prices have been weak for all of
2020 in part because of the shale energy
revolution in America but also in part
to slow global growth it's a problem
we've had since late 2014 since late
2016
there was a mitigation strategy in place
by OPEC members plus a few more key
producers like Russia and Mexico what's
new is that the Cova denied teen crisis
has disrupted Chinese economic activity
and with it global supply chains and the
demand for transport fuel what's also
new is that the 2016 strategy OPEC plus
used to cut production has fallen apart
so we've got way too much oil on the
market which the Saudis are selling in a
discount it's an oil flood we're seeing
free-market movement but it is
weaponized by state-owned oil the Saudis
are trying to starve out shale
production and take market share from
Russia while hoping the Chinese economy
will pick up soon and Cova 19 doesn't
put the global economy into recession
the good news is we have plenty of oil
the bad news is we need the global
economy especially the Chinese economy
to pick up demand do you think the Kovan
19 crisis and declining oil prices are
related let us know in our poll also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI